Ahoj jmenuji se Katy Beslado
jsem ředitelka strategie IBM Quantum
a aplikovaného výzkumu jsem tu abych vyvrátila
co nejvíc mýtů o kvantovém počítání
za šedesát sekund.
Kvantové počítače jsou naprosto reálné
a máme zařízení na IBM cloudu která může teď využít každý.
Ano ale jen pro určité věci ve kterých jsou opravdu dobré
jako extrémně složitá matematika na které běží vesmír
ale když chceš dělat tabulky nebo emaily použij
svůj počítač.
Teoreticky ano ale ne
tak brzy nikdo ještě nevyrobil dostatečně dobrý počítač aby to dokázal
v dohledné době jsme na správné cestě
a až se tam dostaneme změníme způsob jakým chráníme
informace.
To je naprostý nesmysl kvantové počítače
jsou zásadně odlišné
a ke zpracování informací využívají přírodní zákony
dnešní AI běží na pořádných starých klasických zařízeních
ale věříme že v budoucnu budou spolupracovat.
Není to pravda máme ohromný ekosystém
startupů akademické sféry národních laboratoří a průmyslových partnerů kteří
naše zařízení používají každý den.
Ne kvantová inspirace existuje
už dlouho a běží na klasických zařízeních ona
nikdy nenaplní příslib kvantového počítání
pokud chceš kvantové počítání musíš to dělat na skutečných kvantových
počítačích